all right well the media think Trump is
gone on his way out
but is he Trump takes to Twitter to
fight back the Republicans finally pass
a tax bill plus the President of the
United States sounds off on ROI more and
we'll go through all of the biblical
allusions to taxes yes really I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show so
much coming up and I'm gonna give you an
intellectually honest look at whether
President Trump is really in trouble
over this whole Mike Flynn indictment
thing what the Mike Flynn indictment
thing actually means I don't think it
means nearly as much as the media are
making it out to me I think the media
are are way out in front of what the
news is actually showing and in fact it
seems to me that the Flynn indictment in
some ways actually shows that the Muller
investigation is not going to end with
anything except for a political
prosecution of the President of the
United States by Democrats I want to get
to all of that I also want to get to a
huge Supreme Court case that is going to
be discussed tomorrow I'm gonna talk
about the tax bill we'll talk about all
those things but first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at my
Patriot supply so you look around and
you see that their natural disasters on
a regular basis right there earthquakes
in California apparently there's been a
swarm of small earthquakes in California
that are supposed to be leading up to
the big one perhaps we can all hope not
but regardless of whether it happens or
not you should be prepared for any
disaster that may arise whether it is
man-made or whether it is natural this
is what the government suggests this is
what prudent people do this is why you
should go over to my Patriot supply and
you should get there 102 serving
emergency food kit for just 99 bucks the
experts in food storage say it can last
in your home up to 25 years one hundred
and two servings of emergency food for
99 dollars to basically spend a hundred
bucks and now you're safe and your
family is safe from the vagaries of
natural disasters for the foreseeable
future it seems like a great way to make
sure that you're protected you stick in
your closet you forget about it folks in
the office have tried it they say that
it tastes exactly like home cooking
order several kits at this low $99 price
make sure that your family is safe call
eight eight eight eight oh three 14 13 8
8 8 8 o 3 14 13 or go online to prepare
with been calm that's prepared with been
calm the kids include breakfast lunches
and dinners they are shipped free on my
Patriot supply right now right now
America's most trusted food storage
company eight eight eight eight oh three
14 13
31413 or prepare with been calm again
that seems like a cheap price to ensure
that your family is safe so prepare with
then.com okay so we start of course with
the big news that broke on Friday that
Mike Flynn had pled guilty to lying to
the FBI the indictment showed that that
was really all that was there and I had
speculated two possibilities possibility
number one is that he pled to lesser
charges in order to the FBI could get
him to flip on Trump possibility number
two is that this is basically all the
FBI had and now the FBI is just gonna
charge a bunch of people for lying to
the FBI in the absence of any crime
remember when Mike Flynn the former
national security adviser was charged
with was lying to the FBI about him
making phone calls to the Russian
ambassador surrogate kiss Lake on
December 22nd what exactly did he say in
those phone calls that was so all-fired
terrible apparently he called up and he
said President Obama on his way out is
attempting to create these new sanctions
he wants to demonstrate that that
Hillary Clinton lost because we cheated
in the election don't worry about it the
sanctions are never really going to be
taking effect they're not going to
damage you just hold your fire and Putin
said okay okay so that's really nothing
special okay it's a transition team he
was about to enter office as the
National Security Advisor three weeks
later the people who are saying well
it's a Logan Act violation the Logan Act
prevents you from basically making your
own foreign policy but it's not clear
that the Logan Act is even
constitutional it was passed into law in
1799 it has never convicted
anyone in 218 years it is not convicted
a person not one so the idea that
suddenly it's going to be applied for
the Trump administration is absurd
you've seen many Democrats who have
applied their own foreign policy while
Republicans were in office while their
Democrats were in office for them for
that matter and Jimmy Carter basically
ran North Korean foreign policy while
Bill Clinton was in office Teddy Kennedy
tried to go over to the USSR and then
make a deal with the USSR so that they
would help affect the 1984 election
cycle so that he could get in right but
Barack Obama was conducting calls with
other members of foreign governments
long before he took office in 2009 all
this stuff has been happening routinely
so the idea that Mike Flynn did anything
deeply wrong by contact when the Russian
ambassador is absurd also apparently he
asked the Russian ambassador to help
stymie a UN resolution that Barack Obama
was trying to push in his final days to
slap Israel over so-called settlements
and and so kiss lyac was called by flynn
presumably at the behest of Jared
Kushner and Kushner said if you could
back off that day I'd be nice again I
don't see anything wrong with any of
this I really don't see anything
terrible about this but he did lie to
the FBI so now what it looks like is
that Robert Muller is putting together a
bunch of charges based on lied to the
FBI well if this turns out to be a bunch
of people who lied to the FBI about non
criminal activity as I said last week
this sounds a lot like scooter Libby's
scooter libby if you recall was an aide
to vice president dick cheney during the
w administration and there was a story
going around that someone in the White
House had leaked the personal
information of Valerie Plame a CIA
agents in order to get revenge on her
husband Joe Wilson because Joe Wilson
had written a long op-ed in the
Washington Post about how the Bush
administration had been wrong about WMD
in Iraq it turned out that it was
Richard Armitage over at the State
Department who had leaked Valerie
Plame's name but Scooter Libby sort of
either got a conversation wrong or lied
about a conversation to the FBI he was
prosecuted he was put in jail and Bush
commuted his sentence this sounds a lot
like that right scooter libby didn't
actually commit any crime other than
lying to the FBI lines of the FBI is a
crime but if there's no underlying crime
it's not Watergate Watergate was a bunch
of lies about an actual crime a break-in
at the Watergate Hotel that was designed
to put bugs in the Democratic National
Headquarters
okay nothing like that has happened here
there's no evidence of any actual crime
by anyone in the Trump administration
with regard to collusion with regards to
working with the Russian government no
charges of serious crime and all the
rumors that Mike Flynn was going to be
charged with corrupt ties to Turkey or
to Russia
none of that materialized Andy McCarthy
over at National Review here's a really
fascinating piece in which he discusses
at length the idea that there would be
some sort of deal cut where Flynn only
gets prosecuted with the smallest
possible crimes and he's like on the
bigger ones in order to kind of deal
with me says that's not the way it works
with prosecutors Andy McCarthy former
federal prosecutor he says what you do
is you actually prosecute the biggest
crimes and then you say in the plea
agreement that he's going to get off on
lesser years for bigger crimes unless he
works with us because the problem is
once you file charges the charges are
filed right so if all they're filing
charges on are the lesser charges that's
not much of a threat to Mike Flynn so
all this talk about how inevitably the
it must be the mother has something
really terrible on Flynn and Flynn is
gonna say something really terrible
about Trump not a lot of evidence
that in any case so president Trump
responds over the weekend it's not
really bright you know the president of
the United States really should keep his
mouth shut
on this stuff or he should send out his
lawyers to say something but the
president always feels the need to sound
off himself and in doing so he gets
himself in a little bit of hot water
here is President Trump defending my
plane well I feel badly for general
Flynn I feel very badly he's led a very
strong life and I feel very badly John I
will say this Hillary Clinton lied many
times to the FBI nothing happened to her
Flynn lied and they destroyed his life I
think it's a shame Hillary Clinton on
the 4th of July weekend went to the FBI
not under oath it was the most
incredible thing anyone's ever seen she
lied many times nothing happened to her
Flynn lied and it's like they ruined his
life
the most incredible thing anyone has
ever seen in history is what Hillary
Clinton did Hillary Clinton will always
be the go-to for President Trump but
Trump is not wrong when he says that
Hillary Clinton
apparently lied to the FBI I think that
that's probably true and she got away
with it Mike Flynn lied to the FBI and
now it looks like their pillar iing him
is lying to the FBI ok of course not he
committed a crime and if you committed a
crime then he should pay the price for
that crime but the idea that Michael
Flynn was actually trying to cover up
for something more nefarious is not for
now here's where Trump really gets
himself in trouble or at least we don't
have the evidence that yet here's where
Trump really gets himself in trouble so
Trump tweets out this over the weekend
he tweets quote I had to fire general
Flynn because he lied to the vice
president and the FBI he has pled guilty
to those lies
it is a shame because his action during
the transition were lawful there was
nothing to hide okay so he's basically
saying what I'm saying here is that
Flynn lied to the FBI but there was no
underlying crime the problem here is
that what the president is actually
saying is that he fired Flynn knowing
that Flynn lied to the FBI so this a lot
a lot of people to suggest that this was
obstruction of justice right the reason
that it sounds like obstruction of
justice is because James Comey if you
recall had testified that President
Trump told him to let Flynn go and then
he apparently fired Flynn because he had
lied to the FBI so the implication of
this tweet is that Trump knew that Flynn
had lied to the FBI when he fired him
not just lied to the vice president so
if he knew that Flynn lied to the FBI
and then he went to co me and told Comey
then the head
the FBI to let Flynn go a lot of people
I'm left claiming that this is
obstruction of justice it isn't I'll
explain why legally but here is the here
is the flashback of James Comey and the
reason I keep saying his words is I took
it as a direction right I mean it's the
president United States with me alone
saying I hope this I took it as this is
what he wants me to do no I didn't I
didn't obey that but that's the way I
took it you may have taken it as a
direction but that's not what he said
correct that's what I said he said I
hope those are exact words correct you
don't know of anyone that's ever been
charged for hoping something is that a
fair statement I don't as I sit here
thank you thank you right so a lot of
people on the Left hang well you know
what that is that right there that's
obstruction of justice
well Dianne Feinstein is saying this
right Dianne Feinstein the senator from
California she says this looks like
obstruction of justice as you know I'm
ranking on judiciary and the Judiciary
Committee has an investigation going as
well and it involves obstruction of
justice and I think what we're beginning
to see is the putting together of case
of obstruction of justice I think we see
this in the indictments the four
indictments and pleas that have just
taken place and some of the comments
that are being made I see it in the
hyper phonetic attitude of the White
House the comments every day the
continual tweets and I see it most
importantly in what happened with the
firing of director Comey and it is my
belief that that is directly because he
did not agree to lift the cloud of the
Russia investigation okay the problem
here is that there is no clear-cut
obstruction of justice even if he fired
call me let's say worst case scenario he
fired call me because he wanted call me
to stop investigating Flynn there's no
clear-cut investigation obstruction of
justice because the president does have
the power to fire the FBI director for
any reason he sees fit yeah I've
actually looked at the statutes and I'm
gonna go through the statutes right
sunette right now with you on
obstruction of justice as to whether
obstruction of justice actually took
place not clear legally that obstruction
of justice has taken place by the way
the idea that trumps shut down the
investigation is obviously untrue and
special counsel is going forward from
has the power to fire the special
prosecutor Robert molar he is not in
fact done any of that so before I get to
whether this is obstruction of justice
even if the Democrats were suspicions
are confirmed first I want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at saucy so you
know the news cycle moves so fast life
is full of stress at night you want to
unwind that you want to relax you want
some alcohol well that's why you need
saucy saucy is the alcohol delivery app
they deliver your favorite wine beer
liquor right to your door on demand it
is lyft or uber for alcohol so if you're
in LA San Francisco Chicago San Diego
Sacramento your saucy odor will arrive
at your door in 30 minutes or less ready
to drink this happened to me the other
night my wife and I were interested in
in drinking a little alcohol but a rough
day and we didn't have any alcohol in
the house so we so we immediately got on
the saucy app and saucy had somebody
arrive at our door within it was really
I think about 20 minutes with the
alcohol that we desired it's a pretty
awesome thing for the rest of you if
you're not in one of these big cities
then you will have saucy delivered to
you in two days or the last nationwide
so you can order in advance and in two
days the west nationwide it will arrive
anywhere there are no order minimums no
delivery fees no running to the store if
you've got the saucy app you got a fully
stocked bar right there on your phone in
the middle of a party you don't want a
break from the party and so now you just
get on your phone and some schlub shows
up with your alcohol and you don't have
to worry about running out to the local
dales jr. to make sure that you're
actually stocked up for the party for a
limited time you get $15 off when you
download the stasi app and enter promo
code Ben that's the saucy app spelled
sau cey saucy and for promo code Ben for
$15 off get that saucy app today and use
promo code Ben it makes your life a lot
more convenient and honestly there's
nothing that's better than you're
sitting there watching your Netflix and
chilling but you don't have the chill
that's what Stassi provides to you saucy
saucy app and use that promo code Ben
that's correct folks I did just use the
phrase Netflix and chill okay so as far
as obstruction of justice the the
Democrats are basically claiming now
that Trump fired James Comey in order to
obstruct justice
this doesn't wash for a couple of
reasons one the special counsel has
continued his investigation into Russian
collusion and has found nothing
collusion is not a crime and now let's
look at the actual statutes an
obstruction of justice so there are
three separate federal laws that cover
obstruction of justice there's 18 US
Code 1503 this is called the Omnibus
clause it covers quote
roughly or by any threatening letter or
communication influencing or impeding or
endeavoring to influence obstruct or
impede the due administration of justice
but this Clause requires a pending
judicial proceeding and there is no
pending judicial proceeding because
Flint had not been indicted yet now if
Trump were to go to Muller now and say
to him
cut it out let Flynn go then that would
actually be obstruction of justice but
he doesn't have to do that he was
pardoned Flint right which is not
obstruction of justice because he's the
president and that's within his purview
there's 18 USC 1512 C this provision of
law covers anyone who quote obstructs
influences or impedes an official
proceeding or attempts to do so it is
not clear that an FBI investigation is
actually an official proceeding and it's
hard to prove intent in any case it's
and by the way it's not enough to show
intent to violate the subsection you
have to take a substantial step toward
the accomplishment of that goal so again
there's no substantial step taken toward
obstruction and finally there's 18 us
code 1519 and this provision covers
destroying evidence there are no
accusations that President Trump
destroyed evidence in any of this
so is there obstruction of justice no
she's wrong does Trump have the capacity
to fire Comey for any reason the answer
is yes Comey works for him so there's no
obstruction he could fire call me does
that mean that it's smart for the
President of the United States to go out
there and start saying that he knew that
Flynn lied to the FBI and then he fired
the FBI director no that is not smart of
the President of the United States it
gets him in all sorts of hot water and
that's why the president's lawyer came
forward and said I wrote that tweet it
wasn't Trump the idea being that it
doesn't establish Trump's knowledge that
Flynn lied to the FBI if the lawyer
wrote the tweet now what's interesting
is when you watch the conflation of two
separate narratives from the Democrats
Dianne Feinstein I believe is a lawyer
so she knows enough to know that you
can't make charges of collusion without
evidence or you shouldn't or than that
the the Mike Flynn charges don't show
that there is actual cheating in the
election between Russia and the Trump
campaign Joy Behar however is a
and she doesn't know that so Joe by Joy
Behar over at the view she completely
misconstrues the report from Mike Flynn
and you'll hear the crowd cheer as they
think they finally got Trump oh breaking
news ABC News Brian Ross is reporting
Michael Flynn promised full cooperation
to the Muller team and is prepared to
testify that as a candidate Donald Trump
directed him to make contact with the
Russians
and the crowd goes wild for news that
never happened
because it never happened so we reported
on Friday the Brian Ross had said this
on ABC only one problem Brian Ross was
wrong so let's let's get to Trump
fighting back against all of this so
Trump is not a guy who sits down when
when he feels that there's a need to
stand now the president is a counter
puncher as the vice president says and
the idea that the President of the
United States is going to take a back
seat to anyone on this stuff is not true
so the president immediately goes out
front and starts fighting this so he
starts by slamming the FBI itself so he
he goes on Twitter and he says report
anti-trump FBI agent lead Clinton email
probe now it all starts to make sense
he's saying this is witch-hunt that the
FBI was that that the Clinton probe was
led by a bunch of biased people and that
the people who are now going after him
from the FBI are biased as well now it
is certainly certainly the case that
James Comey was biased in favor of
Hillary Clinton there is no doubt
whatsoever that she actually violated
the law and he let her off the hook
preemptively and it's not a surprise
that an anti-trump FBI agent was was
helping Hillary Clinton out the idea
that the FBI is a non-political body is
not true the FBI has always been
somewhat of a political body that does
not mean that local FBI agents aren't
doing their jobs but Trump isn't wrong
about this by the way it is it is
important to question and ask this
question on Fox it still has not been
answered this FBI agent the story here
is that there was an FBI agent who had
texted some nasty things about Trump and
Robert Muller fired him the question is
how Robert Miller fella found out about
it so if Robert Muller found out about
it and fired him then Robert Muller is
is not biased right that would be
evidence that Robert Muller is trying to
do the right thing if he found out about
because the media reported on it and
then he fired him then it might be that
the Muller investigation is inherently
biased
I don't think Muller is necessarily
biased against Trump I think that this
is what special prosecutors do they dig
and they dig and they dig in they dig
until they find a crime and if they
can't find a crime then they get a bunch
of people in there to talk to the FBI
and then they use that to create crimes
and I'm not saying that Mike Flynn was
entrapped Mike Flynn is a an intelligent
guy should have been there with a lawyer
you don't lie to the FBI but it is also
true that the FBI likes to charge lying
to the FBI even when there's no
underlying crime so Trump slams the FBI
and then continues along these lines
he also tweets this Tainted know very
dishonest FBI
agents role in Clinton probe under
review led Clinton email probe Clinton
money going to wife of another FBI agent
in charge so here's Trump going after
the FBI now you know there is something
dangerous about going after the entire
institution of the FBI but to suggest
that there is bias in the Hillary in the
Hillary investigation I think is is
understating the case as I said at the
time the idea that Muller did not indict
Hillary Clinton or at least recommend
her indictment is is pretty astonishing
okay so there is that then he went
directly after James Comey so Comey why
call me is still in the news is really
beyond me I guess just because Comey the
suggestion is the obstructed justice by
firing Comey but Trump says I never
asked coming to stop investigating Flynn
just more fake news covering another
Comey why so Comey is the one who
testified to that Trump is now saying
that he never told Comey to stop
investigating Flynn the evidence on
Trump's side on this is that Comey
didn't actually stop investigating Flynn
and even after Comey was fired the
investigation into Flynn obviously
didn't stop so it's possible that Trump
said I wish that you would see your way
clear to letting Flynn go he's not he's
not a bad guy by the same token that
doesn't really count is telling Flynn to
stop investigated telling Comey to stop
investigating Flynn I mean Trump had the
capacity to make that stop and he didn't
and then he continued along smacking
Comey he said after years of call me
with the phony is dishonest Clinton
investigation and more running the FBI
its reputation is in tatters worst in
history but fear not we will bring and
bring it back to greatness
so he's attacking the FBI so another
institution under attack
now Comey is not helping his case so
Comey goes out himself and decides that
it is worthwhile to tweet so now come
B's on Twitter this is just what we need
everyone on Twitter and James Comey
tweets a bunch of pictures of people in
FBI coats saying I want the people to
know this truth the FBI is honest the
FBI is strong and the FBI is and always
will be independent me June 8th 2017
there is an account called ben shapiro
quote I do retweet it but I don't
actually quote myself okay I don't I'm
not sure that I've ever actually quoted
myself like on Twitter like that James
Comey is you know Trump called him a
grandstander and basically an attention
James Comey is those things so
Trump goes after Comey as well then
Trump goes after the media he's not
wrong to go after bias in the FBI he's
not wrong
after call me by the way and he's not
wrong to go after the media so he starts
slamming the media too particularly
because of this retracted report from
Brian Ross so let's start with the
actual Brian Ross report so Brian Ross
originally reported this about Mike
Flynn and and president Trump he's
prepared to testify we are told by a
confident against President Trump
against members of Trump family and
others in the White House he's prepared
to testify that President Trump as a
candidate Donald Trump ordered him
directed him to make contact with the
Russians which contradicts all that
Donald Trump has said at this point as
well we're told that Flynn made the
decision to cooperate only in the last
24 hours that he is distraught about the
decision but feels he's doing the right
thing for his country that he was facing
huge legal bills of more than a million
dollars and that he said that finally he
had to go ahead and do this for that
reason he sucks to put his house on the
market
he is facing serious financial problems
he so Ross has been in trouble a few
other times for getting the story
completely wrong here he got the story
completely wrong it turns out that Flynn
had not was not going to testify that
candidate Trump told him to contact the
Russians but that president-elect Trump
had told him to contact the Russians
that makes a huge difference
president elect Trump telling him to
contact the Russians is not a big deal
it doesn't go to the question of whether
the Trump campaign was working with the
Russians in the first place so Brian
Ross is forced to retract this here he
is retracting this just over the weekend
he was then suspended for a month
forgetting this report wrong and David
the clarification tonight on something
one of Flynn's confidants told us and we
reported earlier today he said the
president asked Flynn to contact Russia
during the campaign he's now clarifying
that saying according to Flynn candidate
Trump asked him during the campaign to
find ways to repair relations with
Russia and other hotspots and then after
the election the president-elect asked
him to told him to contact Russia on
issues including working together to
fight Isis David before and after in the
meantime Brian we do have a statement
from Michael Flint tonight he said I
accept full responsibility for my
actions that's right and the Flint's
confidence has
extremely angry at the White House
tonight that he was going broke with
crippling legal fees finally Trump's
lets his Trump goes after Brian Ross and
the media and we'll get to that in just
one second so Trump is lashing out at
everyone in part I think justifiably in
part he's making things worse for
himself when he lashes out this way it
makes him look like he has something to
hide even though he doesn't I've said
from the very beginning from the
literally the outside of this that when
he fired Comey it seems to me that the
best possible explanation for what Trump
does is incompetence not malice that
usually it's about President Trump being
angry at something that's going on
firing somebody not about him just
deciding that he wants to cover up some
sort of nefarious crime I'll get to all
that in just a second first I want to
say thank you to our sponsors over at
USC CA so gun lovers I have a huge
announcement for you how does a free gun
sound well you are in luck because right
now the u.s. ECA is kicking off December
with a completely free gun giveaway for
my listeners it's not just one gun you
get four chances to win a Springfield
st. it's the AR that you really want for
Christmas ergonomic grips and enhanced
stock designed to improve speed and
accuracy this is a fun gun and it'll
help you defend yourself too it's also
an expensive gun by the way you should
see it if you want to check it out
defend my family now 1.com that's defend
my family now one calm the digit one
defend my family now one calm - check it
out and be entered for free you have for
free chances to win but that ends soon
don't get left behind again they're
throwing in all the ammo that you need
to break it in as well so a pretty
awesome deal defend my family now one
calm - enter for free let's defend my
family now one.com to enter for free you
get a shot at winning a springfield
state which is an awesome firearm again
help you defend yourself help you defend
your property help you defend your
freedom and you get the chance to win
when you just all you have to do is go
over and register defend my family now
one calm and make sure you use that
digit one defend my family now digit one
calm okay so so Trump Slams Brian Rossi
goes after him here - he's not wrong to
slam Brian Ross okay he's right Brian
Ross was wrong here again I'm not sure
it's worth the president getting his
hands dirty because when the president
does this it gives off an air of
desperation that I don't think is
actually warranted here he says people
who lost money when stock market went
down 350 points based on the false and
dishonest reporting of Brian Ross of ABC
News he has been suspended should
consider hiring a lawyer and suing ABC
for the damages this
reporting has caused many millions of
dollars I don't really think he wants to
go here the fact is the President of the
United States has momentarily tanked
various stocks over his presidency by
naming companies and bashing them if
they can sue over Trump doing that then
you know they can also sue over Brian
Ross I suppose Trump continues along
these lines and he says Trump goes after
the media he goes after Brian Ross not a
shock there and then finally he hits the
Justice Department he's still angry at
his own Justice Department for not going
after Hillary Clinton and really he's
mad at Jeff Sessions and the Justice
Department for not protecting him from
what he feels is a witch hunt and here's
what he tweeted many people in our
country are asking what the Justice
Department justice in scare quotes is
going to do about the fact that totally
crooked Hillary after receiving a
subpoena from the United States Congress
deleted an acid-washed 33,000 emails no
justice and then he tweeted along these
lines again he went after his own goj so
general Flynn lies to the FBI his life
is destroyed crooked Hillary Clinton on
that now famous FBI holiday
interrogation with no swearing in and no
recording lies many times and nothing
happens to her rigged system or just a
double standard again I don't think he's
wrong on all this I just think that the
louder Trump gets the more it looks as
though he has something to hide and
that's a problem for him the best thing
he could do right now is hey listen the
investigation should go forward I didn't
lie Mike Flynn mighta lied to the FBI
but it's about an underlying crime that
doesn't exist and then maybe down the
road when all this when all that comes
out is that it's a bunch of lied to the
FBI charges with no underlying crime he
can always do the Scooter Libby just
commute everybody sentence to me that
seems like the best possible solution
but what's happening here is I think
Trump is getting so upset about this
that now he's thinking about firing
Robert Muller the special counsel once
you fire the special counsel then all
hell breaks loose because people are
going to assume rightly or wrongly that
you really do have something to hide so
whoever is around president Trump should
be encouraging him today not to fire
Muller but to be encouraging Mike Flynn
that he's probably never gonna serve a
day in jail for lying to the FBI about
something for which there's no
underlying crime Chris ruddy who's a
friend to President Trump says that
Muller is an existential threat to the
Trump presidency at this point that's
true in the sense that the more of this
builds up the more Democrats might try
to impeach him but let me put it this
way if the Democrats tried to impeach
Trump over Mike Flynn lying to the FBI
over no underlying crime I would oppose
the impeachment I think so
would most Americans here's Chris ruddy
those saying that Trump is feeling
really threatened you know at the end of
the day my view is that Robert Muller
poses an existential threat to the Trump
presidency he's gotten four major two
convictions two plea agreements
lightning speed
okay I don't think that he posed an
existential threat to the Trump
presidency unless you think that Trump
actually has something to hide if Trump
does have something to hide
then it was Trump that posed in
existential threat to the Trump
presidency not Muller that said this
does not look like this is a in a
political investigation by any stretch
of the imagination
it looks like an investigation designed
to elicit charges of lie to the FBI that
it's not designed to elicit actual
underlying crimes we were told this
investigation was all about collusion
with the Russians has there been any
evidence of that hasn't my wonders I did
anyone for any of that not that I can
really see anywhere here I mean George
papadopolis would be the closest thing
to it and even that is is unclear as far
as the actual collusion okay so I have a
lot more to talk about I don't talk
about tax reform I want to talk about
and I want to talk about a big Supreme
Court case that is coming up tomorrow we
still have to do our Federalist paper
because it is a Monday so we have not
done our assignment yeah so lots to get
to but for all of that you're gonna have
to go over to Daley wire comm and
subscribe for $9.99 a month you can get
a subscription to Daley wire.com and
when you do you get the rest of our show
live on video you get the rest of
Michael Moses show live on video you get
the rest of the Andrew Klavan show live
on video plus you get to be part of my
mailbag and our fourth episode of the
conversation is coming up on Tuesday
December 12th at 5 p.m. Eastern 2 p.m.
Pacific featuring your favorite
parentheses me subscribe today to be a
part of the conversation and ask me
questions which I will either answer or
mock or then answer in the order they
are entered into the live feed my
conversation will stream live on The
Daily wire Facebook page and the daily
wire YouTube channel you'll be free for
everybody to watch only subscribers can
ask the questions if you want to ask
questions as a subscriber log in to our
website daily wire comm head over to the
conversation page to watch the live
stream after that start typing into the
daily wired chat box and I'll answer
questions as they come in for an entire
hour once again subscribe to get your
questions answered by me the
incomparable button Shapiro on Tuesday
December 12 5 p.m. Eastern 2 p.m.
Pacific join the conversation subscribe
now so that you can ask the questions
also if you want the annual subscription
you get all those things and you also
get this the finest in all vessels that
hold beverages the leftist years
or called tumblr you'll treasure it
every moment for your remaining days on
this earth it is just spectacular so you
got all of those things or if you just
want to listen later please subscribe to
our YouTube channel please go over to
SoundCloud iTunes any place you listen
to podcast subscribe and leave us a
review as well we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
all righty so a lot else to get to
president Trump has endorsed Wright more
I'm gonna save that for things that I
hate but first I want to get to tax
reform passing so all of this flin news
has swamped what is the biggest
accomplishment so far of the Trump
presidency
outside of the Gorsuch pick for the
Supreme Court and that is the passage of
tax reform in the Senate I've discussed
sort of the merits of the tax bill
before I think it is a meritorious bill
I think there's a lot that is good to it
the Democrats are suggesting that it is
just the worst thing ever Patton Oswalt
the insufferable comedian who was also
the voice of the rat Remy in in
ratatouille he tweeted out is there any
going back after this tax bill scam to
America does it matter now if Trump is
impeached
there's no America now not the one we
knew sorry feeling real despair this
morning wait like we cut I get to keep
more of my own money and that ends
America that's like the end of it like
we're done dunzo turn out the lights
finished finito benito mussolini like
what why didn't the what in the world
it's okay so after the obamacare
decision came down from the Supreme
Court I said that America had been
fundamentally changed the reason I said
that is because a basic principle of
Americanism had been ripped away that
principle was the government cannot
force you to buy things right they until
then the idea the government could force
you to buy an entirely optional products
with no externalities on anyone else
this is a brand new concept and that
fundamentally changed things it violated
my liberty it installed a new tent pole
for tyranny in the United States I can
force you to not buy anything I want and
I can force you to buy anything I want
that's full-on control of my life
Patton Oswalt however thinks that if I
get to keep more of my own money that
this is the end of America there's no
America now now listen you cannot like
the process by how this bill was passed
I'm not real fond of it it was crammed
through it was it was done with
handwritten notes in the in the margins
by the way that's not as rare as it
seems they've been a bunch of Congress
people who've done that before that odd
frank bill had handwritten notes in the
margins all of that said it was rushed
through without proper evaluation or
debate that was done because senators
didn't want blowback but is it it's a
pretty typical Republican bill I mean
it's not like there's anything
groundbreaking here the biggest problem
with the bill is that is that it doesn't
it doesn't cut expend
which is really what I wish Republicans
would focus on right now Republicans
inflate the deficit by cutting taxes
even though the tax revenues in the long
run grow it may not make up for the tax
revenues that are lost in the short run
meaning the government takes in the less
money Democrats blow out the budget by
increasing spending even if they raise
taxes
I don't think Republicans shouldn't
lower taxes I just think they need to
pair that with some actual cuts which I
highly doubt they will do and so we
continue to kick the can down the road
on our debt but the idea that is this is
the end of America it demonstrates that
for the left they've truly believed I
mean they really do believe that it is
the government's job to control your
life and anything the government doesn't
do to control your life is bad for
America the more the government does to
control your life the better it is for
America I'll show you the proof so Larry
Summers former president of Harvard
former Clinton Treasury secretary and he
predicted 10,000 people would die per
year because of tax reform today on CNBC
there's pretty clear evidence looking
across different states and looking when
health insurance has been phased in and
out when people lose health insurance
they're less likely to get preventive
care they're more likely to defer health
care they need and ultimately they're
more likely to die and it's very hard to
quantify precisely my piece explains why
an estimate that thousands will die as a
consequence of this bill is actually a
very conservative estimate because the
reason he says that is because the bill
also gets rid of the individual mandate
it doesn't force you to buy health
insurance but the idea here is that if
the government doesn't force you to buy
health insurance and you opted not to
that is the same as the government
killing you that's in the same okay that
means that the government didn't force
me this morning to get up and wrap
myself in bubble wrap the government
didn't get wake me this morning and say
you have to eat healthy today that means
the government is killing me I'm not
telling me what to do the government is
killing me this is precisely the reverse
of the notions of American liberty
enshrined in the Constitution of the
United States and the Declaration of
Independence but it goes further than
this there are a bunch of commentators
who are out there saying that it is
irreligious all these religious
Christians who back the tax reform bill
the hell is wrong with these people
so there's guy named Jonathan Martin and
James Martin rather who is a who is a
Jesuit priest and he tweeted this out
the US will soon face the consequences
of a tax bill that takes money from the
poor to give to the rich this is false
the money that the bill does not take
from the poor to give to the rich it
allows rich people to keep their own
money it allows poor people to keep
their own money says those who voted for
it will face consequences later when
they are judged in hell done tom tom
says do you think Jesus is worried about
being judged on Holi care for the poor
don't apply think again and then he
brings the hammer boom okay and he's not
the only person who's speaking religious
sophistry there's a female rabbi named
Daniel Bruton burg and she tweeted
something out like if the Bible is so
against systemic solutions to poverty
why is a Jubilee year declare that
releases people from debt to alleviate
intergenerational poverty what is
Luckett shittaka
pea and moss era if not tax is meant to
create a safety net for those in need so
in a second I'm gonna go through
actually what the Bible says about taxes
but I first want to point something out
the Bible never says that it's the
government's job to provide for the poor
it says that it is your job to provide
for the poor this is why religious
people give significantly more charity
than religious people it's why
conservatives give a lot more personal
charity than non conservative people so
all the people who are generous with
everybody else's money by using the
government as a cram down mechanism for
welfare all those people are happy to
use my money in the ways they see fit
but they are not willing to actually dip
into their own pocket and make it happen
the reason that whether you talk about
Jesus we're talking about the Old
Testament all of the religious sources
in judeo-christian history have been
talking not about what the state should
do but about what you should do how you
have a religious obligation to help out
the poor and the needy and the widow and
the orphan and now I'm going to actually
go through the Bible so they're a bunch
of people who have complained before
about well you know you're a religious
person Ben you wear a yarmulke and yet
there are a bunch of things in the Bible
to talk about taking care of the poor
okay now I'm gonna go through that I'm
going to show you what sort of taxes the
Bible is talking about to take care of
the poor okay number one the Bible talks
about tax is explicitly twice I'm
talking here about the the Tanakh the
the Old Testament it talks that you use
the hebrew word which is mas que mas
means tax in in hebrew he it only uses
it twice in the entirety of the of the
Torah in the prophets and in the
writings okay uses it with regard to the
King Rehoboam right who is Solomon's son
Solomon raised taxes and then his son
raised taxes and the actual effect of
that is that the Kingdom Israel split in
two because taxes were too high talks
about that
a little bit later in the in the profits
and then ah hush vero shahe swear us in
in the poram story raise taxes at the
end of the story demonstrating his
mastery over the far-flung domains
neither in in neither context are the
taxes seen as something good the talmud
especially rips into the tax of OshKosh
B'gosh
okay now let's talk about other biblical
forms of tax first there's tithing
again we talked about tithing she's
talked specifically it's talking about
something in Hebrew that's called master
Shanee now I know I don't wanna get too
abstruse here with the biblical teaching
but since I actually do read the Bible
in the original Hebrew I'm gonna use
some Hebrew terms here mas'r Shanee is
tithing that's the tithing that we
always talk about for the poor but
here's what the Bible actually says
about that in Deuteronomy okay the four
the original there's actually two sets
of tithing in the Torah there's moss air
and there's master SHANY master
literally means one-tenth so mass air
and mass are SHANY mass air is for the
Levites master Shanee is for the poor
and the orphans in the widow's okay it
only applies in the third and sixth
years of the sabbatical cycle and is ten
percent of produce okay so that's a 10%
tax every third and sixth year for the
widow and the orphan okay then there's
something called chica ha that's when
you forget a sheaf in the field is also
in Deuteronomy you're supposed to leave
it for the widow and orphan so you're
walking around and you leave one or two
sheets for the widow and orphan okay
that's pretty de minimis okay then there
is a lekha and pea
these are referenced in Leviticus 19 lek
it is referring to ears of corn that you
forget on the ground same sort of thing
you're gleaning your crop and you forget
an ear of corn on the ground leave it
there for the poor and then there is pea
which refers to leaving a corner of your
field for the poor and the widow right
the minimum amount for pea is one
sixtieth of your field so at best we are
talking about a biblically mandated
11.7% of your produce every third and
sixth year okay that's what the Bible
says it's hard to talk about how the
Bible is saying well you have to give a
hundred percent of your everything to
charity
it's nonsense in fact in Judaism once
you hit a certain once you got I believe
it's 20% of your of your money to
charity you're supposed to think
seriously about whether to get more than
that because you're actually
undercutting your own ability to take
care of your family Democrats are
talking about maintaining tax rates of
above 50% okay so don't talk to me about
what the Bible says about taxes
okay then they talk about to further
biblical provisions there's shemitah
which is the sabbatical year every
seventh year you leave the land fallow
the idea there was that the land is
going to recover and then there's yobbo
yo've oh is every fiftieth year all of
the land sales that have been made in
the prior 50 years revert back to their
original owner both of these were
supposed to get rid of loans one of the
problems that happen is that it turns
out people stopped giving loans at all
so what did the rabbi's do the Talmud
says that they designed something called
a prose boule which was a basic legal
war legal workaround so you could
continue to lend his lending ground to a
halt also the purpose of having all the
land revert back to its original owners
in the fiftieth year was not to create
some sort of socialist system where he
can't sell land or aggregate wealth the
purpose was they didn't want tribal land
moving from one tribe to another Yeovil
does not apply the Jubilee year does not
apply when all the tribes don't live in
Israel and aren't separated by tribe
okay so there is your basic biblical
breakdown I know that's more specific
than most people would want but the idea
that the Bible mandates that you are
supposed to give enormous amounts of
charity via government compulsion is
just not true it's not true in the
slightest okay other big story today
final big story then we'll get to some
things I like things I hate and the and
the and the Federalist Papers the other
big stories that tomorrow there's a big
case at the Supreme Court it's called a
masterpiece cake shop case so we've
talked about this before
the masterpiece cake shop case is a
seminal one for both religious liberty
and freedom of association basically
there's a guy named Jack Phillips jack
is a baker in Colorado he makes he
decorates cakes he will make a cake for
any one gay couple straight couple green
couple doesn't matter he'll make a cake
even for your gay wedding what he won't
do is decorate it in particular styles
he's not gonna use his artistic skill in
order to in order to make a wedding cake
for a gay wedding so he's not going to
decorate a cake that says happy gay
wedding John and Bob right he's not
gonna actually take one of those cake
toppers with two dudes and stick it on
top of the cake that's something that
Jack is not gonna do so the leftist at
the Colorado Civil Rights Commission
said the jack has to be forced to
violate his own religious beliefs as a
result of their own ruling he lost 40
percent of his business more than half
of his employees all by about all for
abiding by his biblical beliefs the left
says the government should be able to
force Jack to decorate the cake for the
gay couple for their wedding okay this
is vert this is viscerally anti religion
it's also anti freedom of association
and Sarah Jones is a leftist columnist
in The New Republic here's what she
here's what she says and I think this is
right she says what Phillips wants is
for the law to wait his personal beliefs
about a person's intrinsic ident
above that person's right to access a
business I guess that's fair
what Phillips wants is for his personal
beliefs to be able to be invoked in his
business dealings as we all would like
right I don't think that if you're a
leftist radio host you should be forced
to have me on your show I don't think
that if you're a leftist speech writer
you should be forced to work for
President Trump and use your artistry to
that effect I don't think that if you're
a gay business owner you should be
forced to bake me a cake that says on it
Leviticus 18:22 I don't think you need
to do any of those things because I'm
for freedom freedom only exists in the
spaces where we acknowledge that we have
no right to someone else's labor or
approval tyranny grows when we refuse to
approve those spaces this is about
tyranny it's not even about religion
it's about do you have the freedom to
act in ways you see fit even if others
don't like it and even if it means that
others can't take advantage of your
services the answer is was and always
will be constitutionally yes that is why
I believe fully that you are able to
turn away whomever you want from your
business and yes that includes for bad
people right racist can turn away people
what anti-semites can turn away Jews you
know it'll happen I'll walk across the
street races can turn away black people
you know it'll happen they'll walk
across the street and those races will
go bankrupt as I've said in a thousand
speeches at this point the fact is the
capitalism doesn't care about color it
doesn't care about Creed all the cares
about is cash and if you're turning away
a vast bevy of clientele you're
undermining your own business okay time
for things I like things I hate and then
we'll go through a federalist paper
really quickly so things I like so over
the weekend I had a chance to read some
Elmore Leonard never actually read his
stuff I had watched a little bit of the
series justified if you watch that
series it's based on a short story
called fire in the hole and Elmore
Leonard is a crime writer he's really
quite good I really enjoy his writing
he's very straightforward he's not
deliberately obscure so I've read a
couple of really good crime writers in
the past a couple of weeks Don Winslow's
who's early stuff I read one of his
books that I didn't like very much
though the legend the life and death of
bobbies he wasn't very good but his book
on the cartel was great and fire in the
hole there's another very very good book
of short crime stories there's a reason
that Elmore Leonard's best-selling
author check it out Elmore Leonard fire
in the hole it's kind of its kind of
westerns it's basically westerns and
they're pretty great okay time for some
things that I hate
all right so the thing that I hate today
is that the president has endorsed the
Roy Moore the president came out and
tweeted that he supported Moore and that
you should support Roy Moore - he then
called up Roy Moore personally and lent
his support has anything changed from
when these allegations were originally
made about Roy Moore for child
molestation the answer is no nothing has
changed it is certainly possible the
President of the United States could go
around saying don't vote Doug Jones
right don't vote Doug Jones you want to
vote right in whatever you want to vote
for Roy Moore all right
but don't vote Doug Jones you could have
said that right and just made it into a
lesser of two evils choice by overtly
endorsing Roy Moore it is very difficult
to escape the public perception that
your pooh-poohing the actual child
molestation allegations now Democrats
have no leg to stand on here since
they're gonna let Al Franken sit in the
Senate after we have pictures of him
trying to grow up a woman's breasts
while she's sleeping Democrats don't
have much of a leg to stand on so long
as John Conyers is in Congress so long
as Bill Clinton is still an honored
member of their society that said is
this good for the country no it's not
good for the country when you're gonna
have an alleged child molester sitting
in the Senate he's probably gonna win
and I think that he'll be seated I think
that the idea that the Senate is going
to not seat him is is foolish I think
now a novel seat him now that Al Franken
is staying he'll be seated and you see
that Mitch McConnell is making those
moves to here's Mitch McConnell in
Alabama saying we'll let the people of
Alabama decide whether he ought to be
seated well I think we're gonna let the
people of Alabama decide a week from
Tuesday who they want to send to the
Senate and it will address the matter
appropriately I've already said in the
past that I thought this was a matter
that would have to be considered by the
committee ultimately would be up to them
to make that decision and they'll make
it depending upon whether a judge Maury
ends up coming to the Senate do you
believe the judge more should be in the
Senate I don't let the people of Alabama
make the call to move on to move by
McConnell in the wrong direction so
we've seen all these politicians
basically fussing over these allegations
first you had Nancy Pelosi defending
John Conyers now you have Mitch
McConnell basically defending Roy Moore
everything is getting worse and worse on
this score because no one is willing to
take a moral stand and take a temporary
loss you do wonder you know back in 1993
I think it was David Duke ran for Senate
in Louisiana and the Republicans said we
would rather you vote for the Democrat
than David Duke you do wonder today if
the Republican Party would do that or if
it Emma
party would do that if the case were
reversed we may be so partisan that
we're beyond saving here okay so quick
correction so last week even during my
Corrections I screwed up a correction so
now I'm going to correct another thing
as I try to make clear folks I'm frying
that when I make a mistake at least I
try to fix it okay
so Theresa May I said was selected on
the basis of her of her being Pro brexit
that is not true she didn't actually I
have a position on the referendum she
had been I guess my you know sort of
anti brexit but then when she came in
and she pledged that she was going to
enforce brexit I had a guy named Richard
who wrote to me and he says as Home
Secretary Theresa May took the position
of the UK government and endorsed remain
but what made her position sufficiently
ambiguous to get herself selected by
both sides of the Conservative Party was
that the pot was the fact she didn't
take an active part in campaigning for
remain okay I hope I have corrected this
to everyone's satisfaction now okay now
I'm gonna go briefly from Federalist
Papers from Federalist number six so
we're gradually making our way through
the Federalist Papers the Federalist
Papers are very long there are 85 of
them we are now from number six we are
gradually making our way Federalist the
first five Federalist Papers or at least
three of those five we're basically
devoted to why America should be one
country now we're going to talk about
the possible conflicts between the
states and why you need a stronger
centralized government than the Articles
of Confederation could provide in order
prevent conflict between the states so
what's really fascinating in this one is
Alexander Hamilton writes if Hamilton is
of the three guys writing the best
writer Hamilton's a very lucid and
powerful writer and Hamilton makes the
case against the idea that the states
will be at peace without a strong
central government there are much people
who said why do we need a strong central
government all the states will get along
well in doing so he actually debunked a
couple of very popular twentieth and
twenty-first century notions the idea of
democratic peace theory the democratic
countries don't fight each other and the
idea that countries that do commerce
don't fight each other so he debunked
both of these which is really
interesting because I agree with
Hamilton
he says the genius of Republic's say
they say his opponents is Pacific
meaning that they are peaceful the
spirit of Commerce has a tendency to
soften the manners of men and to
extinguish those inflammable humors
which have so often kindled into Wars
commercial republics like ours will
never be disposed to waste themselves in
ruinous contentions with each other
meaning this is this is what they've
often called the McDonald's arches
theory of diplomacy that countries that
have been donald's and free Commerce are
less likely to go to war with one
he says they will be governed by mutual
interest will cultivate a spirit of
mutual Amity and Concord but then he
says have Republic's in practice been
less addicted to war than monarchies are
not the former administered by men as
well as the latter the founders are
constantly focusing in on human frailty
human weakness and human flaw and that's
why the constitution is such a grand
document Isis are there not aversions
predilections rival ships desires of
unjust acquisitions that affect nations
as well as kings in other words
democracy is not a cure-all for war
which is obviously true we've seen
democracies go to war with one another
Hitler was an elected official and the
Soviet Union originally was a popular
movement it was a minority popular
movement but it was popular most as I've
said before
virtually all fascist nations in the
West started off under democratic
auspices before power was either seized
or democratic means were used to elevate
a bad guy to power Sparta Athens Rome
Carthage were all Republic's as Hamilton
two of them Athens in Carthage of the
commercial kind yet were they as often
engaged in Wars offensive and defensive
as the neighboring monarchies at the
same times meaning they being a
commercial republic is not going to save
you and then he says from this summary
of what has taken place in other
countries whose situations have born the
nearest resemblance to our own what
reason can we have to confide in those
reveries which would seduce us into an
expectation of peace and cordiality
between the members of the present
Confederacy in a state of separation in
other words if we don't have a strong
centralized government the states are
gonna be fighting each other in five
seconds have we not already seen enough
of the fallacy and extravagance of those
idle theories which have amused us with
promises of an exemption from the
imperfections weaknesses and evils
incident to society in every shape he
says there's always gonna be conflict
that's why we need to band together
against all outsiders instead of banding
together against each other he says it's
time to awake from the deceitful dream
of a golden age I love the realism and
to adopt as a practical maximum for the
direction of our political conduct that
we as well as the inhabitants of the
globe are yet remote from the happy
Empire of perfect wisdom and perfect
virtue and this is so different from how
the left thinks that human beings are
capable of something that's why we have
to have a world government this is why
if every man were left to imagine in
John Lennon's style everything would be
all better the founders were ultimate
realists and that's why their words are
still important because well we may have
different notions of how government
ought to work they were more correct
than we because our notions of human
nature are worse than theirs okay so now
we we have
reach the end of today's show there will
be a lot more to discuss tomorrow as
always I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show the Ben Shapiro show is
produced by Mathis Glover executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our technical producer is
austin stevens edited by alex singhara
audio is mixed by Mike or Mina hair and
makeup is by Jess while opera the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright for
publishing 2017